[Музика]
Ем
добре, хлопці, привіт, я радий знову бачити вас
у своєму класі, і, як ви бачите сьогодні, у нас є
нова тема, і ми збираємося говорити про
роботу та кар'єру, я думаю, що  це
дійсно важлива тема, особливо для
підлітків,
хлопці, ви закінчуєте школу, ви
тільки на початку свого життя, і
вам потрібно
дуже ретельно подумати про свою майбутню
кар'єру,
тому що ваше життя насправді залежить від
цього, залежить від вашого вибору того, що
ви  зробить, щоб заробити гроші на своє
життя або отримати
більше задоволення, або, можливо, ви зможете поєднати
своє хобі та свою кар'єру, тому
перш ніж ми почнемо, нам точно знадобиться трохи
словникового запасу,
тож давайте зробимо це таким чином, сьогодні ви
побачите
три картинки  і три слова
я не прошу вас поєднувати їх все
буде дуже
просто, але я прошу вас скласти
речення з цими трьома словами,
можливо, ви зможете скласти одне
речення і використовувати
всі три слова лише в одному реченні,
давайте почнемо
так  перші слова є
співбесіда художня та конкурентоспроможна,
тому щоб бути на співбесіді,
іноді потрібно бути артистичним
і, безумовно, потрібно бути
конкурентоспроможним,
запишіть слова та складіть
власне речення,
можливо, ви скажете, що Енні справді
артистична,
вона збирається стати художником  одного дня
або міша дуже конкурентоспроможний,
йому подобається брати участь у різних
конкурсах,
і він зазвичай перемагає, або
ви можете сказати, що я боюся співбесіди на роботу,
добре три слова, і ми можемо піти
далі наступні три слова -
освіта, хороша мова та працьовитість
освіта - це те, що ми отримали в школі
та університеті
я можу сказати, що я добре володію мовами я
знаю
російську українську англійську трохи
німецьку
французьку і давно я вивчав
фінську,
тому можу сказати, що я добре
володію мовами  Працівники,
усі ви, хто дивиться ці відео
та виконує завдання,
ви справді працьовиті люди,
добре складіть власні речення та
запишіть ці слова,
давайте рухатися далі  оплачувана робота
страхування та вакансія
настільки високооплачувана робота, що це означає, що ви можете
отримати багато грошей
або ви можете отримати інші нагороди від
цієї роботи
, яка винагороджує страхування роботи
може бути медичним страхуванням або страхуванням життя,
наприклад, моя компанія моя школа
надає мені
медичне страхування, це означає, що
компанія
ставиться до мене добре, і вони хочуть, щоб я був
здоровим,
відкриваючи оголошення, яке ви бачите на
веб-сайті, коли вони кажуть, що
хлопці, що ми наймаємо, нам потрібно більше вчителів,
нам потрібно більше будівельників, нам потрібно більше
спеціалістів з ІКТ, тому відкриваємо роботу  коли
люди кажуть,
що вони когось наймають, добре,
давайте сформулюємо речення,
я маю високооплачувану роботу,
крім того, моя компанія надає мені
страховку,
і я був дуже радий відповісти на
цю вакансію, добре, наступні
слова ось вони – підвищення,
я звільняюся і професійний
дегустатор  не тестувальник,
а дегустатор просування по службі
означає, що коли ви піднімаєтеся по кар’єрних сходах,
ви починаєте, наприклад, із секретаря,
а потім стаєте менеджером, а
потім старшим менеджером  ger, отже, це
заохочення
я звільняюся, люди зазвичай кажуть цю фразу,
коли хочуть залишити роботу
і кажуть, що я закінчив, я звільняюся,
а професійний дегустатор - це той, кому
потрібно щось скуштувати, наприклад,
тістечка чи вино чи інші продукти,
як-от чай
кава щось подібне, так що вони
професійні
дегустатори, добре, давайте складемо речення
невдовзі після того, як вона отримала підвищення,
вона сказала, що я кинув наступні
три слова зарплата
вирішує проблеми і втомлива
добре, зарплата - це сума грошей, яку ми
отримуємо,
вирішувати проблеми означає бути в змозі виправити
і не мати проблем і втомлення
означає, що ти справді втомився і
робота справді
виснажує речення
моя робота може бути трохи втомливою,
але хороша зарплата вирішує всі
проблеми,
тому мені вдалося зробити три слова в одному
реченні.
зробіть те саме, давайте перейдемо
до наступного робочого місця тренер
працює з цифрами
я дуже сумую за своїм робочим місцем я дуже сумую
за спортом, тому що в цьому році у
нас є багато справді крутих тренерів, які
o є вчителі, і
я не люблю працювати з числами, мені подобається
працювати з людьми
, тому я став вчителем
добре наступні слова: робота сама
робота з людьми і спорт,
тож давайте спробуємо зробити ще одне речення
мій тренер, який цього не робить  любить
працювати наодинці і хто віддає перевагу
працювати з людьми, дійсно спортивний,
наступний
працює на відкритому повітрі, працює в приміщенні, а
астрономи можуть працювати і в
приміщенні, і на відкритому повітрі, вони можуть спостерігати
за зірками і вони можуть
працювати в лабораторіях, хлопці, що б
ви
хотіли працювати в приміщенні  або працювати на свіжому повітрі,
а наступний останній,
тож у нас є бонуси за робочі години та
креатив, тож бонус
– це те, що ви отримуєте більше, ніж
просто зарплата,
це додаткові гроші, які ви отримуєте за свою
кваліфікацію або за гарну роботу,
вони  може бути від дев'яти до п'яти
або вони можуть бути будь-якими іншими робочими годинами
та креативними для деяких робіт, вам потрібно
бути
справді креативними, у неї є фіксований
робочий час
і хороша річна
премія, тому що вона справді креативна  ative,
ось моє речення, а що щодо ваших
речень,
я сподіваюся, що ви записали всі слова,
і я хотів би, щоб ви склали свій квізлет
і вивчити ці слова за допомогою quizlet,
і ми йдемо далі, подивіться тут.
Робота неможлива без людей
і  Чи не могли б ви вивчити вакансії та
сказати, які з них люди, наведені нижче,
підходять для використання виразу, з якого
він чи вона буде хорошим,
наприклад, бухгалтер-бухгалтер у
людині, яка
рахує гроші та веде бухгалтерський облік
для компанії,
а потім директора компанії, керівника  програміст
компанії
добре, зараз усі знають
про Силіконову долину
і, можливо, буде багато ІКТ-
спеціалістів з України,
тоді прийде архітектор людина, яка
проектує
та планує будівлі електрик
це дуже важлива робота, тому що всім нам
потрібна
електроенергія і ця людина допомагає нам
отримати  це в наших домівках,
а потім торговий представник
ці люди представляють нам нові бренди
або продукти, і вони приходять у різні
магазини і кажуть, добре, хлопець  Нам потрібно
це продати, і ми маємо це,
тому вони є торговим представником,
а потім приходить цегляний шар,
вони допомагають архітекторам, насправді
вони будівельники, вони беруть цеглу
, вони будують стіни, а потім вони
будують будівлі,
пожежник, пожежник
- це дуже важлива робота  якщо у вас
виникли проблеми, якщо десь виникла пожежа,
ви повинні зателефонувати їм, і вони
обов'язково допоможуть,
тоді секретар або помічник,
вона або він допомагає іншим людям на роботі
в офісах,
вони вели книги, а також вони оформляють деякі
документи,
і вони насправді допомагають нам з  наш
будівельник офісних робіт - це загальне слово для
будь-яких інших робіт, пов'язаних із будівництвом
приватний детектив, вони не дуже
популярні в Україні,
але вони дуже популярні в західному
світі,
і іноді люди наймають приватних
детективів для вирішення деяких
проблем, потім приходить
викладач університету викладач університету  це той,
хто працює в університеті
, читає лекції, і це відрізняється
від того, щоб бути викладачем,
але  все-таки це справді дуже цікаво,
тож, будь ласка, скопіюйте ці слова, вони вам
знадобляться для наступної
вправи
добре, хлопці, давайте рухаємося далі, у вас є ці
слова, і у вас є речення,
давайте прочитаємо речення та скажемо найбільш
підходящу роботу для  людина,
давайте почнемо фразу з того, що вона чи вона
буде добре, а потім скажемо, що робота
добре, тому перше речення Пол не
дуже комунікабельний, але він має дуже
аналітичний склад розуму і добре вирішує
проблеми,
тому яка робота дійсно підходить для  Пол у
нього аналітичний розум і він добре
вирішує проблеми
давайте почнемо фразу з того, що він був
би хорошим я думаю, що
приватний детектив він добре думає
і він добре вирішує проблеми добре, давайте
подивимося на друге речення
Сара дуже впевнена та комунікабельна
людина
вона не боїться розмовляти з незнайомими людьми,
вона комунікабельна і балакуча, можливо,
Сара була б хорошим торговим
представником, тому що торгові
представники
їм потрібно зустрічатися з новими людьми і
говорити про них  t продукт, який вони збиратимуться
продати наступний, Марсель не має
особливої освіти, але він дуже добре володіє ру
ами, можливо, він закінчив лише школу, мо
ливо, він не ходив до університету, але ві
дуже добре володіє своїми  руки,
щоб Марсель був хорошим
будівельником, наприклад,
або муляром, наступний, і він
має дуже хороші навички спостережливості
і приділяє особливу увагу деталям,
він також любить пригоди і
дуже сміливий,
добре, я думав, з Полу
вийде хороший приватний детектив
але насправді Енді, здається, краще
підходить,
як ви думаєте, хлопці,
ви вирішуєте, і ми рухаємося далі, наступний:
Кетрін захоплюється будівлями,
вона досить творча
і добре в математикі,
якщо вона креативна, і вона добре розбирається
з числами,
і вона захоплюється, вона захоплюється
Будівлі,
то вона була б хорошим архітектором,
потім приходить Майк не має жодної
кваліфікації,
але йому подобається допомагати людям і він
не боїться
небезпеки, він не боїться небезпеки,
тому  можливо, він може стати муляром
або будівельником, якщо йому потрібно піти кудись
високо,
на жаль, у нього немає жодної
кваліфікації,
наступна Шеллі дуже добре розбирається в
цифрах,
але вона трохи сором'язлива і зазвичай
вважає за краще працювати на самоті,
якщо вона любить цифри  і вона
воліє працювати сама,
тоді вона б змусила хорошого
бухгалтера працювати в тиші, і
насправді вони не зустрічаються з
іншими людьми, вони зустрічаються з цифрами, і
вони працюють з числами,
і останнє речення Деніел - це його власний
бос, якого
він не може уявити  працює на когось
іншого,
він не може уявити, що працюватиме на
когось іншого,
і він директор компанії, можливо, він
навіть є власником цього бізнесу,
тому він хоче правити, але він не
хоче мати
когось вище за нього, можливо, у вас є
інші варіанти
не соромтеся ця відповідь відповіді відкриті
відповіді. Просто придумайте і приймайте власні
рішення,
і ми йдемо далі, хлопці,
тепер ви повинні зіставити описи
з їхніми
протилежностями так антоніми протилежності
давайте поглянемо  k за першим столом, тому це
дуже
втомливо, це може бути дуже напружено,
це добре оплачується, ви працюєте довгі години,
це означає, що ви запізнюєтеся, і ви
не йдете
додому, коли робочий день закінчується,
це дуже складно, це може бути
дуже неспокійним, коли ви зустрічаєтеся  багато людей
це може бути небезпечно, вам потрібна дуже хороша
кваліфікація
, тому давайте подивимося на протилежності.
можеш піти додому раніше, тобі не потрібен
диплом,
ти почуваєшся дуже ізольованим,
хлопці, ти повинен зіставляти протилежності,
як-от плюс і мінус, добре, подивіться,
я дам вам кілька хвилин, а потім
я покажу вам відповіді, і ми
обговоримо  трошки
добре, хлопці, ви готові перевірити,
тож я розкриваю відповіді, подивіться,
тож перший з них – давайте прочитаємо цю
пару,
вона дуже втомлива,
а навпаки, вона справді захоплююча та
цікава, тому tds
нудний і захоплюючий і  цікавий як
хороший,
добре, другий - це d
це може бути дуже стресовим стресовим
протилежне
слово розслабляє, тоді ми переходимо
до третього, це добре оплачується
і погано оплачується
добре і погано, номер чотири
ви працюєте багато годин, і це йде на g
ти можеш піти додому рано, довгі години ти
залишаєшся допізна на роботі і йдеш додому рано ти йдеш
з роботи
рано, потім настає номер п'ять,
це дуже складно, це дуже
важко,
і у нас є ідіома, що це шматок
пирога,
коли я кажу, що щось є
Я маю на увазі, що це дуже легко,
наступний номер шість може бути
дуже неспокійним,
це означає, що дійсно багато речей
відбувається
саме в цей момент, і навпаки,
зазвичай немає чим зайнятися,
дуже зайнятий і  навпаки - спокій
і нічого робити, потім приходить номер
сьомий,
ви зустрічаєте багато людей, і правильна
відповідь -
ви відчуваєте себе дуже ізольованим, коли ви
ізольовані, ви
нікого не зустрічаєте, а номер
восьмий може бути небезпечним для
протистояння
сайт безпечний, тож він
дуже безпечний, тоді вам потрібна дуже хороша
кваліфікація,
а тут очевидне протилежне:
вік, вам не потрібен
ступінь, означає освіта, а синонім
— кваліфікація,
якщо я кажу, що маю свою кваліфікацію, це
означає, що я  Я отримав
диплом викладача і маю необхідну
кваліфікацію,
але для деяких робіт нам не потрібна ця
кваліфікація
і нам не потрібен ступінь добре, хлопці,
давайте далі, давайте прочитаємо текст, і
мова піде про роботу  про
доглядача зоопарку,
що ви повинні робити під час читання, я б хотів,
щоб
ви занотували слова, які ви бачите
жирним шрифтом, а фрази, які ви бачите жирним шрифтом,
наприклад, я працюю так, як ви бачите їх жирним шрифтом,
вони виділені, тому, будь ласка,
слідуйте  я читаю
і записую ці жирні фрази, які
вам знадобляться для наступної вправи
добре, хлопці, слідкуйте за мною в читанні
я працюю доглядачем зоопарку я відповідальний
за
годування та догляд за тваринами в зоопарку,
це також моя робота прибирати
клітки для тварин
повідомити про проблеми зі здоров’ям а  і розважати
відвідувачів
для цієї роботи вам потрібна спеціальна
кваліфікація,
наприклад, ступінь в галузі біології або
зоології,
звичайно, ви повинні мати любов
до тварин, кожен вид відрізняється
від інших
і вимагає особливої уваги та догляду, ви
акож повинні вміти вести об
ік  тому що ви повинні зібрати багато
даних для кожної тварини,
і ви повинні бути комунікабельними, тому що вам
потрібно проводити
екскурсії для відвідувачів і відповідати на їхні
запитання,
я вважаю свою роботу дуже цікавою,
я завжди любив тварин, тому догляд
за
тваринами більше схоже на хобі, ніж на хобі
робота,
але іноді вона може бути трохи брудною та втомливою,
наприклад, коли вам потрібно чистити
клітки,
і це також може бути трохи небезпечним,
особливо коли тварини хворіють,
вони можуть нашкодити вам, але в цілому
мені дуже подобається моя робота, я можу"  не уявіть, що ви
робите щось інше, хлопці,
ще трохи часу, щоб ви закінчили
записувати фрази,
наступне завдання –
зіставити записані фрази
з запитаннями, які ви бачите  але перед цим
давайте обговоримо
це питання, чи хотіли б ви працювати
доглядачем зоопарку
чому чи ні я не знаю
я, можливо, я б не хотів працювати
доглядачем зоопарку
я люблю тварин, але я трохи
боюся хижаків
і  мені не подобаються запахи, хоча
я дуже добре поводжуся зі своєю собакою, і
я доглядаю за своєю собакою, але дикі тварини -
це щось зовсім інше,
добре, хлопці, давайте подивимося, тож
ось запитання,
що ви робите, і якщо ви чуєте таке
питання, на яке
ви можете почати відповіді з я працюю
, щоб ви могли сказати, що я працюю вчителем,
наприклад, якщо говорите про мене,
то я запитаю вас, що ви робите,
що ви прикидаєтеся, що ви на п’ять років
старше вас,
і ви кажете, що я  працюю торговим
представником
або я працюю секретарем
або я працюю
будівельником друге питання, які ваші
обов'язки
це означає, що за що ви відповідаєте
на роботі і з яких фраз ви
б почали свою відповідь,
щоб записати їх  і
якби мені довелося почати відповідати на це
запитання  я б використовував
ці дві фрази, я відповідальний за
навчання дітей, і
це також моя робота — піклуватися
про дітей, ви бачите,
що після кожної фрази є різні форми дієслова,
якщо ви скажете, що я відповідальний
за, тоді ви повинні сказати робити  щось
наприклад ви лікар і
які ваші обов'язки
ви кажете я відповідаю за лікування
людей друга фраза це також моя
робота
писати рецепти
добре наступне питання ви бачите, що
є більше рядків для наступного
які навички або кваліфікації  вам
потрібно
добре переглянути фрази, які ви
записали,
і як ви почали б відповідати на
запитання,
використовуючи фрази, які є у вашому
списку, добре,
давайте подивимося, що ви можете почати
з цієї потрібної вам роботи, якщо запитаєте мене
про мою викладацьку роботу  які навички та
кваліфікація вам потрібні
для цієї роботи вам потрібно добре знати свій
предмет ви не можете викладати, якщо ви не знаєте
свій предмет,
вам також потрібно вміти
слухати т  студенти, якщо я не слухаю своїх
студентів,
я не отримую зворотного зв’язку, і я не знаю,
чого їх навчити,
чого вони дійсно потребують, і знову те саме
питання,
які навички або кваліфікація вам
потрібні,
ви повинні бути терплячі, якщо говорите про
вчити, що
ти повинен бути терплячим, професійним
і толерантним, і є маса
інших прикметників, якими ти повинен
бути, і останнє питання, якою є твоя робота,
тож у вас є решта фраз,
і вони
відповідають цьому питанню, і вони
я знаходжу свою роботу  це може бути трохи,
а також може бути трохи добре,
знову говорити про викладання, я вважаю
свою роботу захоплюючою,
вона може бути трохи втомливою, а остання
може бути трохи приголомшливою, коли у мене
багато завдань, коли у мене багато завдань  речі, які
потрібно зробити
лише за один день, але я повинен сказати, що
робота вчителя дійсно винагородна,
добре, тому давайте продовжимо, хлопці,
тож давайте поговоримо про вашу роботу, ви
повинні зіставити вирази ліворуч
зі словами справа, я буду читати
з вами  колонка на л  eft
я працюю як я відповідальний
за це також моя робота
для цієї роботи, яка вам потрібна,
тоді ви повинні бути хорошими
в роботі може бути трохи, і я вважаю свою роботу
всі фрази, які ви записували під
час читання,
зараз візьміть  хвилину і спробуйте
зіставити ці початки речень
з їхніми закінченнями
добре
[Музика]
добре, хлопці, тож у вас був час, зараз давайте
перевіримо,
тому я розкриваю відповіді, ось вони,
тому першими я
працюю барменом або менеджером з продажу
лікарем рейс  медична сестра вчителька, тож
після цієї фрази ви повинні
сказати свою роботу номер два
я
відповідаю за телефонну відповідь я відповідальний за
приготування їжі
я відповідальний за навчання продавців
або навчання дітей, тому ці косі риски
показують вам варіанти номер три,
це мій  робота до і правильна відповідь:
електронний продаж будинків організовувати зустрічі
дизайн веб-сайти ремонт автомобілів
будь-які роботи, а після двох вам потрібно
використати форму інфінітиву,
потім номер чотири для цієї роботи, яка вам потрібна,
і подивіться ступінь з хімії
та м  ba магістр ділового
адміністрування
це для топ-менеджерів сертифікат
з викладання
іспанської мови, якщо ви хочете викладати іспанську одного
дня,
то прийде номер п'ять, і це
f, тож давайте прочитаємо все речення, вам
потрібно вміти
продавати, ви повинні бути хорошими в  працювати в команді,
ви повинні вміти спілкуватися з людьми,
вам потрібно вміти працювати з
дітьми,
ви бачите, що вам потрібно добре вміти, а
потім
з’являється або іменник, як-от робота в команді,
або форма, як-от продавати
розмовляти, працювати добре,
номер шість, яку роботу можна отримати  ритм
і правильна відповідь: g робота може
бути трохи
напруженою або вона може бути трохи напруженою,
нудною, небезпечною та виснажливою.
Це всі прикметники, які ви використовуєте, щоб
описати
свою роботу, і останній, який я вважаю
свою роботу, це дійсно захоплююча
або  дуже цікаво або захоплююче
і дуже мотивує я можу сказати,
що
моя робота справді мотивує, я вважаю її
захоплюючою та цікавою добре, хлопці,
багато словникового запасу під час цього уроку,
я б хотів,
щоб ви дивилися на нас  tube,
будь ласка,
зупиніться, і чи не могли б ви записати
весь словниковий запас, який вам потрібен,
і чи не могли б ви, будь ласка, створіть свої
групи слів
і вивчіть весь словниковий запас добре, хлопці,
я знаю, що ви любите грати в Kahoot, і у
нас є кілька ігор Kahoot, і ми граємо
zoom
з усіма вами, хто приєднується до мене в instagram,
тому якщо ви хочете приєднатися до інших zoomka hoots,
приєднуйтесь до мене в instagram, переходьте за посиланням
і грайте з нами,
і це буде домашнє завдання для вас,
тому посилання буде для перших 100
студенти, які хочуть грати
з нами на диску, тож переходьте за посиланням
та насолоджуйтесь англійською, слідкуйте за оновленнями,
будьте в безпеці, мийте руки до побачення
[Музика]
ви